es gibt konkrete pläne den mars für uns
menschen bewohnbar zu machen und zwar
mit der hilfe eines künstlichen
magnetfeldes denn so könnte das leben
auf dem roten planeten vor der
schädlichen kosmischen strahlung
geschützt werden ein britisches
forschungsteam hat genau dafür jetzt
einen plan vorgelegt und der ist
ziemlich ausgeklügelt klicks um sein
feature gibt es da mal pro woche
spannende science wie das abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los ganz
herzlich willkommen menschen auf dem
mars schon längst nicht nur inhalte für
science fiction romans kolonien schon
seit jahrzehnten realität sind
stattdessen ist der rote planet in
visier der forschung und zwar als eine
zweite heimat für uns menschen so sieht
es unter anderem tesla und spacex chef
elon musk er ist felsenfest davon
überzeugt dass wir eines tages den mars
besiedeln werden und dabei ist er
zusammen mit seinem team super ehrgeizig
und motiviert an der sache denn geht es
nach allen masc kann lediglich eine
autarke statt auf dem roten planeten das
fortbestehen der menschheit sichern doch
bis wir menschen auf dem mars leben
können ist noch einiges zu tun im
klartext ist hier vom sogenannten
terraforming die rede durch das andere
planeten in bewohnbarer erdähnlichen
himmelskörper umgewandelt werden könnten
und in diesem zusammenhang gibt es jetzt
einen ganz neuen aber konkreten und
spektakulären plan ein britisches
forschungsteam hat vor allem die
gefährliche strahlung auf dem mars ins
visier genommen in einer aktuellen
studie schreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
von der university of oxford niemann dem
roten planeten zu einem künstlichen
magnetfeld verhelfen könnte der
hintergedanke
dieses magnetfeld könnte wie anstrahlen
schutzschild wirken und das über leben
auf dem roten planeten ein stück weit
realistischer werden lassen denn ohne
einen schutz gegen die kosmische
strahlung wird es auf dem roten planeten
schwierig wie genau das gelingen könnte
und welche besondere rolle dabei der
mars mond phobos spielen könnte all das
und noch viele weitere spannende infos
gibt es jetzt hier bei pixum salz im
flugzeug allen masc ist bei weitem nicht
der erste der pläne schmiedet um den
mars bewohnbar zu machen bereits vor
knapp 40 jahren 1984 schlug der physiker
james lovelock
treibhausgase in die atmosphäre zu
bringen so genannte perfluorcarbon pfc
hunderte produktionsanlagen so groß wie
autos könnten dann die marsoberfläche
temperatur innerhalb von 100 jahren um
20 grad in die höhe steigen lassen love
rocks berechnung zufolge also von minus
60 grad celsius auf minus 40 grad
celsius das co2 aus den polen würde in
die atmosphäre übergehen als
treibhausgas würde es für einen weiteren
temperaturanstieg sorgen auf etwa plus
20 grad celsius innerhalb von 6 100
jahren das wasser als würde sich
verflüssigen was die bildung von
mehreren und seen zur folge hätte durch
einen hohen atmosphärendruck würde seine
verdunstung verhindert werden innerhalb
einiger jahrhunderte wäre der mars also
warm und feucht relativ perfekte
lebensbedingungen für uns menschen wäre
dann noch einen sauerstoff atmen system
wichtig etwa sowie taucher sie nutzen
noch perfekter wäre es natürlich wenn
sich das co2 in der atmosphäre sogar in
sauerstoff umwandeln ließ eine mögliche
idee algen die viel co2 aus halten
dadurch könnten dann auf pflanzen auf
den mars gedeihen doch leider ist die
photosynthese der pflanzen zu diesem
zweck nicht wirklich effektiv
schätzungen zufolge würde es eine
million jahre dauern das co2 das maß in
sauerstoff zu verwandeln würmer und
insekten dagegen könnten schon deutlich
früher auf dem mars leben als wir
menschen heutzutage ist ihnen maske der
vorreiter in sachen terraforming des
mars auch er will den roten planeten
also wärmer und bewohnbar machen seiner
ansicht nach gibt es zwei möglichkeiten
um diese ziele wahr werden zu lassen
thermonukleare waffen könnten über den
eiskappen der maßvolle eingesetzt werden
um die atmosphäre des planeten zu
erwerben juba so tritt settlements vor
zwei jahren 2009/10 schwach radioaktive
kernfusion explosionen über der mars
atmosphäre könnten dem mars also im
besten fall zu einem lebensfreundlichen
planeten verwandeln muss betont dass
diese methode nicht riskant sei und der
mars dadurch keinesfalls radioaktiv
würde das wäre also der schnelle weg und
in elenas worten folgendermaßen
formuliert schmeißt thermonukleare
bomben über die pole
wasserstoffbomben könnten also über den
maßvollen gezündet werden das wasser das
in den ice polen des mars steckt würde
dann verdunsten doch nicht nur wasser
auch kohlendioxid würde freigesetzt
werden und ein treibhaus effekt
hervorrufen denn die treibhausgase
würden nicht nur die mars atmosphäre
erwärmt sondern auch deren dichte
erhöhen so dass auf dem planeten
flüssiges wasser existieren könnte zudem
könnten sich astronautin astronauten
auch ohne druck anzug auf dem roten
planeten aufhalten und noch einmal einen
mast geht davon aus dass durch die
zündung von thermonuklearen bomben im
weltraum nur sehr wenig radioaktive
strahlung entstehen würde doch andere
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind das skeptisch ob diese atomwaffen
plan auf dem mars aufgehen würde gibt es
überhaupt genügend co2 auf dem roten
planeten um den gewünschten
treibhauseffekt zu provozieren würde
nicht zu dem auch das vorhandene co2 aus
der atmosphäre ins all sie kann und so
für den plan verloren gehen und falls
der plan doch aufgehen würde würde die
so entstandene mars atmosphäre überhaupt
bestehen bleiben würde nicht wieder eine
erosion durch den sonnenwind stattfinden
fest steht diese ganzen prozesse sind
noch lange nicht ganz verstanden und so
vermutlich würde die atmosphäre erst
einmal für eine zeit bestehen bleiben
zudem sind auch die folgen für das klima
auf dem mars nicht abzuschätzen
abgesehen davon ist auch die umsetzung
von mas plan anzuzweifeln denn wie
alleine sollen so viele kernwaffen zum
mars geschaffen werden berechnungen
legen nahe dass alle kernwaffen auf
dieser welt auf eine etwa 1 70 der
benötigten energie kommen würden um das
pohl trockeneis auf den mars zu
sublimieren um die drei millionen bomben
sind demnach notwendig und solch eine
hohe anzahl an sprengköpfen muss ja auch
erst einmal zum mars gebracht werden um
einige probleme zu umgehen könnten laut
ihnen maske aber auch sonnen reflektion
satelliten eingesetzt werden dazu hatte
er mal getwittert das könnte sinn machen
tausende von sonnen reflektor satelliten
zu nutzen um den mars mit künstlichen
sonnen zu erwerben fest steht jedenfalls
ohne frage auf der oberfläche des mars
herrschen lebensfeindlichen bedingungen
meistens herrschen zweistellige
minusgrade und die atmosphäre besteht zu
95 prozent aus kohlendioxid sie ist sehr
dünn und besitzt kein schützendes
magnetfeld doch genauso eines ist
wichtig um planeten vor sonnenwind und
hoch energetischen ionisierenden
teilchen von der sonne
als auch aus den tiefen des universums
abzuschirmen auf der erde ist das kein
problem denn der großteil der kosmischen
strahlen wird von unserer magnetfeld
abgefangen und abgelenkt auf dem mars
aber ist das anders alles leben hier
wäre der gefährlichen strahlung
bedingungslos ausgeliefert der mars
rover curiosity der nasa hatte eine
durchschnittliche strahlendosis von 77
mikrosievert pro stunde während des
flugs zu oberflächen das maß gemessen
und immerhin noch 26 mikrosievert pro
stunde auf der oberfläche zum vergleich
auf der erde liegen die werte zwischen 0
05 und 0 2 mikrosievert pro stunde doch
das magnetfeld der erde lässt sich nicht
einfach so nach bilden das durch
komplizierte prozesse zu stande kommt
hierbei spielt vor allem ein dynamo
effect im metallischen erbt kann eine
rolle der auf der rotation der erde
basiert und zwar in kombination mit der
platten tektonischen bewegungen auf dem
mars kannst gar nicht denkbar da das
innere des roten planeten nicht nur
kleiner sondern auch kälter ist ein
britisches forschungsteam von der
university of oxford hat sich jetzt
genau mit diesem problem intensive
befassung einen konkreten plan vorgelegt
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler schlagen eine art zitat
künstliche magnetosphäre für den mars
vor eine zitat völlig neuartige idee
eine entscheidende rolle könnte hier bei
phobos spielen es handelt sich um einen
von zwei monden der sich in einer
gebundenen rotation um seinen planeten
befindet alle acht stunden umkreis vor
boston mass und der abstand zur
oberfläche beträgt dabei lediglich 6000
kilometer dieser mars mond soll also
dabei helfen den mars zur erde zu machen
die wissenschaftlerinnen wissenschaftler
schlagen vor einen künstlich geladenen
teilchen ring rund um den mars
aufzubauen ein sogenannter plasma tores
inspiration für diese idee lieferte der
monti der genau einen solchen ring um
den jupiter bildet doch wie könnte ein
solcher künstlich geladener teilchen
ring um focus geschaffen werden in der
studie heißt es dass partikel auf focus
ionisiert und beschleunigt werden
könnten so dass diese dann einen plasma
ring entlang der umlaufbahn bilden denn
dann so die forschenden würde an
magnetfeld erzeugt stark genug um die
marsatmosphäre zu schützen die fachleute
bezeichnen ihre idee selbst als die
löhne mit der geringsten leistung
anordnung und masse die oxford
physikerinnen und physiker sind also
fest davon überzeugt und ziehen
folgendes fazit jetzt beginnt eine neue
ära der weltraumforschung und es ist an
der zeit über neue und kühne zukunfts
konzepte nachzudenken was
so will ihnen mast dem mars lebens
freundlicher machen hier gibt es mehr
über ihre mass idee den mars mit
atomraketen zu bombardieren also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran